bienvenue à questions d'info alors après
les attentats la donne et les conditions
du débat politique ont elles changé
sur quoi en tout cas vont se jouer les
élections régionales et comment
envisager la france de l'après second
tour l'union nationale à l'heure où une
nécessité invité de questions d'info
aujourd'hui françois bayrou le président
du modem également maire de pau est à
mes côtés pour vous interroger monsieur
bayrou françoise fressoz ce du monde
frédéric dumoulin de la sp et yaël goosz
de france info monsieur bayrou bonjour
bonjour le président de la république ne
verse pas encore là la courbe du chômage
mais celle de sa popularité s'envole +20
points dans le dernier baromètre sofres
pour le figaro magazine 50% d'opinions
positives selon un sondage ifop pour
paris match
est ce que vous trouvez monsieur bayrou
que le président a bien géré la séquence
comme on dit post attentats en tout cas
il a rempli sa fonction avec dignité et
il a fait ce qu'il fallait faire pour
l'essentiel est donc de ce point de vue
là c'est normal que l'opinion publique
traumatisée par ces événements
bouleversé par ces attentats qui touche
la france au plus profond face corps
autour de celui qui a la charge pour
l'instant de l'exécutif de l'armée au
fond de la sécurité des français donc
certes un certain éventuellement nicolas
sarkozy laisse entendre que si ce qui a
été décidé après les attentats du 13
novembre avait été décidée après les
attentats de janvier je viendrai pas eu
ces attentats du 13 novembre
oui vous voyez bien que toujours la
polémique peut reprendre ses droits
et après tout ça ressemble assez bien au
réflexe normal qui sous-entend départ
effet les normales pas au réflexe normal
d'une démocratie en période électorale
on cherche à récupérer des sujets
et à trouver des contestations
électorales étaient chargés au prix non
je ne suis pas dans cet état d'esprit je
ne dis pas que on n'aurait pas pu faire
mieux
je suis absolument certain que tous les
responsables pense qu'on aurait pu faire
mieux
mais vous savez surveiller cette comment
je pourrais dire cette hydre qui a
protéiforme qui a mille formes mille
bras sans qu'on sache exactement de quoi
il s'agit ou de doux se préparent les
ces événements dramatiques et c'est ces
attentats si grave
bien sûr que c'est que ça n'est pas
facile et il est normal qu'on apprenne
de l'expérience alors lui avait donc et
c'est normal aussi et il est juste aussi
de dire que tout cela a des causes le
bien sûr que la syrie est une des causes
permettez moi de dire que la libye aussi
est une alors on y reviendra là dessus
j'ai donc dit il est normal que les
français fassent score derrière le chef
de l'état oui et est ce que vous vous
tous vous juger qu'il fasse il faut
également faire corps derrière l'état
d'urgence car on entend quand même
certaines voix qui commencent à poindre
pour critiquer à gauche et à droite avec
le si dernièrement par exemple dominique
de villepin oui dominique de villepin
qui je rappelle avait établi l'état
d'urgence sont des mises les banlieues
n'est ce pas voilà voilà
et qu'il keqiang il le rappeler en 2005
tout ça je participe à ce genre de
sentiment tout le monde voit bien un la
gravité de la situation de la nécessité
d'écouter ceux qui dans les forces de
sécurité et au sein de la justice ont
besoin d'outils pour agir pour ne pas
dire d'armes pour essayer de faire
reculer ce
cette épouvante moi je suis tout à fait
partisan des décisions qu'on doit
prendre dans cette affaire là même si
net je le croyais que je l' ai déjà dit
à ce micro même si je pense qu'il
faudrait toujours dans une action de cet
ordre qu'il y ait une présence de la
justice j'avais évoqué vous vous
souvenez des magistrats antiterroristes
qui soit au sein des des unités sur le
drame de lee titrisation et quand bien
même il serait allongée trois mois comme
l'a proposé 20 pas comme l'a proposé
mais comme ne l'a pas exclu le jeu sera
coûteux financièrement et ce sera
prolongé de trois mois pour moi
normalement au jeu aucun je peux me
tromper mais vous voyez bien que bien
entendu le dispositif on va pas le lever
demain matin c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
j'insiste pour qu'il y ait une présence
de la justice antiterroriste s'il leur
mais avant au 102 au sein des unités qui
prennent les décisions de perquisitions
ennuis la suède as d'assignation à
résidence
toujours on sait bien qu'il faut agir
on sait bien que pour agir il faut des
instruments efficaces et ses instruments
efficaces
ils doivent aussi avoir à l'intérieur de
leurs centres de décisions des
magistrats y compris des magistrats
spécialisés qu'ils soient là pour
assurer qu on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
est ce que ça dit je ne me je ne sens
pas une seconde en france que les
libertés se trouve menacé les libertés
entre guillemets se trouve menacée par
les décisions est-ce qu'ils contrôleront
ne manifeste pas dans les rues de de
france jusqu'au printemps si on prolonge
dedans y aura des accommodements avec
tout ça bien sûr que la liberté de la
liberté de manifestation est une liberté
mais vous voyez bien que la question est
si lourde et si grave
aujourd'hui que à mon avis il est
pas fondées d'ouvrir dès polémiques sur
la manière dont l'état de droit lutte
contre ces horreurs qui nous ont assez
injustement un certain nombre d'appels
qui sont lancées contre cet état
d'urgence notamment
on appelle ce qu'on appelle appelle des
58 intellectuels artistes politiques
avec notamment signé notamment par noël
mamère
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je partage
pas ce sentiment je ne sens pas les
libertés menacées au contraire parce que
je pense que la sécurité est la première
des libertés et je pense que on a on a
le plus grand besoin de garantir la
sécurité pour toutes les raisons qui
touche à notre vie de famille à nos
inquiétudes pour les enfants ce ne sont
pas des situations ordinaires veut dire
arrêtons nous unissons voulais dire
c'est une situation qu'on a jamais
connue en france bon il ya eu des
d'autres formes mais du temps de l'es2
puis une autre forme
mais franchement vous avez un attentat
aveugle et dont la logique d'être
aveugle par des gens qui sont drogués à
la mort qui veulent tuer et mourir et
qui viennent tuer cent trente enfants
130 jeunes garçons et filles pour
l'essentiel c'était des jeunes
vous avez vu la liste bouleversante et
il y à des menaces que ça se reproduise
et qui sont pas minces franchement on
prend les précautions
où est le bon sens quand on a
l'impression que il ya des gens qui
vivent mal le fait qu'on prenne des
précautions
moi je suis pour qu'on prenne des
précautions et je les assume et vous
allez 6 mai n'est pas un sujet de
polémique politicienne de droit de
justice alors une question est ce qu'il
faut aller jusqu'à la révision de la
constitution pour en quelque sorte
institutionnalisée l'état d'urgence pas
d'abord faut voir le texte alors qu'il y
ait petit habiletés de françois hollande
politique jouer c'est à dire le
contraire l'union nationale pas vous
dire le contraire mais
ce qu'il y a dans la constitution c'est
les pleins pouvoirs de l'article 16 et
l'état de siège
bon vous voyez bien que la situation
d'exception ou enfin d'inquiétude de
mobilisation nécessaire dans lequel nous
sommes ne relève ni des pleins pouvoirs
de l'article 16 ni de l'état de siège
qui est un état de siège militaire
eh bien vous voyez que il n'est pas
illogique d'essayer de définir avec
l'opposition
si j'avais un message à faire passer au
président de la république c'est qu'il
essaye d'en discuter avec les
commissions parlementaires avec
l'opposition parce que il faut faire
adopter le texte dans les deux
assemblées les majorités 3 5e est
ensuite il faut faire adopter par le
congrès à une majorité qualifiée donc
regardons les regardons les choses parce
que je crois pas que ce soit injuste
un sujet de référendum donc iard et le
petit habilitées du chef de l'état oui
vous ne comprendriez pas vous
personnellement que l'opposition ne vote
pas ce texte
bon je sais bien qu'il va y avoir des
débats autour de ce sujet pour ne pas
donner un avantage au président de la
république moi ceux à qui je ne veux pas
donner un avantage ce sont les
terroristes
d'abord ce sont ceux qui attaquent notre
pays d'abord après je préférerais que le
président de la république s'abstiennent
des habiletés mais peut-être peut-être
est-ce que je rêve d'un monde idéal
alors vous dites
je ne veux ce qui ne veut pas donner l
avantage ce sont d'abord les terroristes
il ya quelque chose qui a échappé aux
médias les réseaux sociaux sont très
actives depuis le 13 novembre dimanche
l'islamologue qu'on appelle comme ça et
frères musulmans tariq ramadan a posté
sur son compte son message pour le moins
curieux je vais le site et je suis ni
charlie ni paris je suis perquisitionné
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
bon je pense que tout le monde devrait
faire attention et que ce type de
message qui a une signification enfin a
une signification qui pour moi est une
signification inquiétante
pourquoi pourquoi parce que ce type de
message vise à séparer les musulmans de
la communauté nationale
or pour moi les musulmans font partie de
il ya des musulmans qui ont été
assassinés et parmi les victimes il ya
évidemment les 130 pauvres garçons et
filles en particulier les plus jeunes
qui ont été assassinés il ya leurs
familles qui sont déchirés n'est
guériront jamais il ya le pays tout
entier qui est inquiet pour sa sécurité
et parmi ceux là il ya les musulmans qui
trouve depuis des mois depuis des
semaines depuis ces événements que le
regard sur eux a changé est-ce qu'il
faut interdire ce sens mais en ajoutant
ils se sentent ciblées et donc le
message qui dit je suis du côté des
perquisitionné à bhl c'est un message
qui coupe le pays selon une ligne de
fracture que pour moi je n'accepte pas
parce que je veux que le pays soit soudé
tout entier quelle que soit sa religion
quelle que soit son origine
parce que nous sommes tous victimes et
tous s'y vit à l'union sacrée même pas
c'est la solidarité nécessaires à
l'intérieur d'une maison quand la maison
et les statistiques de messages il faut
l'interdire
ça vous choque préférerais qu'ils
n'existent pas après interdire comment
vous fait d'interdire qui sera en
meeting de même le 11 mai prochain ça
allait revenir sur les réseaux sociaux
tout ça alors juste extrêmement hautes
ils interdits et mais vous voyez bien à
ce que ce que je veux défendre devant
vous c'est l'idée que conserve l'unité
de la communauté nationale et qu'on
passe pas son temps à séparer et diviser
les français selon leur origine selon la
religion
tariq ramadan là c'est un tweet de tariq
ramadan mais il vient sur une scène en
meeting le 11 décembre prochain la
semaine prochaine à saint denis
on peut laisser autorisé maintenir ce
genre de réunions publiques bon j'essaie
de pas tout mélanger
c'est au gouvernement et c'est à la
justice de dire ce qu'il doit en a il
faut qu'ils se posent la question
d'argent
j'imagine qu'ils se posera la question
est qui sera pas le seul j'imagine que
beaucoup de gens se poseront la question
je vous dis essayons non pas de faire
des déclarations péremptoires mais
d'avoir du bon sens le bon sens indique
que dans des moments d'inquiétude et de
crise comme cela il faut être prudent
dans la manière dont on présente les
choses
riffaud être du côté de l'unité du pays
et pas du côté de la division du pays
vous parlez de bon sens donc là en fait
la france est en guerre contre le
terrorisme
est-ce qu'elle en a les moyens cette
guerre la guerre entre le bouclier et le
et l'épée c'est une guerre qui dure
depuis le début des temps il faut
renforcer les moyens mais pour ça il
faut écouter les professionnels ceux qui
assument la lutte faut écouter les
magistrats antiterroristes faut écouter
les responsables des services de
renseignement faut écouter responsables
des forces de sécurité
faut écouter ce qu'ils connaissent bien
les dynamiques internes de ces
mouvements parfois effroyables
bref il faut faire un travail qui est un
travail de deux réunions de nos forces
de nos forces françaises ou de nos
forces au niveau international john
kerry qui dit les etats-unis demandent
aux alliés de l'otan d'intensifier ses
attaques contre l'état islamique
oui je il faut intensifier les attaques
contre l'état islamique qui dirige et
perpètrent ce genre de choses mais il
faut que nous nous renforcions sur notre
sol c'est la série tv avant temps pour
moi c'est le plus important et nous ne
pouvons pas nous renforcer sur notre sol
si nous n'avons pas une démarche de
coopération étroite avec les forces de
sécurité et de renseignement des pays
qui nous entourent des pays frontaliers
je ne sais pas il ya probablement il ya
une déclaration qui peut être échappé
aux observateurs
l'état islamique a dit nous allons
procéder par fra public fera public
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
on prend des allemands pour intervenir
en belgique des belges pour intervenir
en france des français pour pour frapper
en espagne on va on va se servir pour
abattre les démocraties des frontières
parce que nous savons bien disent les
terroristes ou pensent les terroristes
que les forces de renseignement d'un
pays ne travaille pas avec les vivants
du dossier est bon pour attendait cette
si on peut finir cette phrase de ce
c'est très important
il est impossible de lutter contre cette
hydre s'il n'y a pas une coopération
étroite des polices et des services de
renseignements de tous les pays
concernés et particulièrement et
singulièrement des pays européens
on ne peut pas le vous voyez bien la
seconde ce qui se révèle par par bribes
et par morceau c'est que les services de
renseignement garde le renseignement
pour eux or c'est de l'autre côté de la
frontière que ça se joue
si vous n'êtes pas capable de faire ça
alors vous l'appelez comme vous voulez
vous vous l'appelez schengen voulait
justement schengen c'est fini ou pas
c'est c'est c'la plus immenses
nécessités ce qu'on peut reprocher à
schengen c'est de ne pas exister à ses
vous comprenez pas ce que dit nicolas
sarkozy
oui mais quand même bon je pense que
c'est parce qu'il dit mais qu'on venait
qu'à cet instant précis des entretiens
ça n'est pas mon sujet ça se parle de
l'afrique aussi mais moi je vous dis
avec certitude que la question c'est que
schengen ne trouve pas son efficacité
parce qu'on ne fait pas marcher à c'est
tout le monde l'a dit vous êtes des
observateurs vous lisez tout le monde a
dit mais les services de renseignement
ne changent pas leurs scellés enfin des
éléments dont il est un mois que la
belgique c'est mais pas seulement
tout laissait réellement parce qu'ils
ont l'impression que c'est leur affaire
et que et donc tant qu'on n'aura par
cette volonté des changes on n'y
arrivera pas je vais vous donner un
exemple précis que nous avons vécu que
j'ai vécu comme vous le savez j'ai été
président du département des pyrénées
atlantiques pendant de longues années
c'était l'époque des attentats de eta
tant que chacun est resté chez soi le
taa c'était très simple pour elle elle
préparait des attentats en france et l
aller les accomplir en espagne et tout a
changé le jour où les services de
renseignement les services de police et
les magistrats anti terroristes ont
décidé qu'ils allaient travailler
ensemble et qu'ils échangeraient tous
leurs renseignements sami au bout du
compte avec le temps un ca mis un terme
à ces attaques et eta a fini par déposer
les armes c'est pas le seul sujet mais
c'est pas la seule cause mais c'est une
cause très importante
on a fait reculer le terrorisme à partir
du moment où on a collaboré coopérer de
part et d'autre de la frontière et c'est
possible aujourd'hui en europe
vous êtes le jeu suivant cet engin que
c'est possible à condition qu'ils aient
des responsables suffisamment volontaire
et suffisamment compétent pour imposer
ces échanges là quand vous pensez que
tout toutes ses forces de sécurité de
renseignement ont des fichiers et les
échanges pas entre eux et donc vous avez
quelqu'un qui rentre il est parfaitement
à l'abri die à la frontière il faut
comprendre que une frontière où on
n'échange pas qui sépare deux services
de renseignement où on n'échange pas les
renseignements c'est le meilleur allié
des avec des rôlistes est d'ailleurs
aussi des mafias avec avec avec l'oci de
la variable turc et jusqu'où voilà
jusqu'où les frontières de l'union
européenne d'en parler de schengen
parlons maintenant des frontières plus
largement le débat est relancé
la turquie fallait-il que bruxelles
donne 3 milliards d'euros d' aide à la
turquie et repose la question de son
éventuelle intégration à l'union
européenne en échange de la part des
turcs d'une meilleure gestion des
réfugiés est ce que ce deal là est un
bon deal selon vous petit rappel
historique
je me suis toujours opposée à l'adhésion
de la turquie à l'union européenne vous
souvenez que ça avait fait des débats
considérable que des tas de gens à
droite et à gauche étaient pour et que
un des arguments que j'utilisais sait
que le contexte géopolitique dans lequel
la turquie et géostratégiques et géo
sociologique et géopolitique dans lequel
la turquie vit et agit pour ses intérêts
n'est pas le contexte européen et c'est
ce que nous vérifions tous les jours et
vous n'allez pas vous rend ce nom où en
serions nous si la turquie était au sein
de l'union européenne
et si l'incident de l'avion avec la
russie s'était produit avec un pays
membre de l'union européenne ou encore
youtube le membre de l'otan où en
serions nous
raison pour laquelle j'ai jamais été je
n'étais pas favorable retour au sein du
commandement avec les responsables de la
part des temps de re donner l'impression
que les négociations s'ouvrent
ouvre oui vous voyez c'est des habiletés
là encore après il ya une autre question
oui mais il ya aussi on voit bien que
dans ceux d'il ya aussi la nécessité
pour l'europe de 20 de demander à la
turquie de jouer pleinement son rôle ya
également sa wii avec les migrants oui
c'est normal mais en même temps je vais
dire les choses autrement est ce qu'il
est normal pour prendre non pas nos
frontières à l'est mais nos frontières à
l'ouest que ce soit la france qui
doivent faire le garde frontière de la
grande bretagne qui s'ouvre opposés et
que et que est ce que c'est normal et
que les accords qui ont été signés à
l'époque n'est pas pris en compte cette
nécessité
moi je pense qu'il faudrait que la
grande bretagne soit présente avec nous
sur notre sol pour traiter ce genre de
questions les magistrats anglais les
forces de renseignement ou de sécurité
de manière qu'on puisse accepter ou
refuser les gens qui sont à calais et
qui bon je trouve que ce n'est pas
normal
mais de la même manière il n'est pas
normal que la france demande à l'italie
tout seul de faire son garde frontières
et je ne trouve pas que ce soit un bon
équilibre de penser que c'est la turquie
qui va devoir régler ce genre de
questions contre espèces sonnantes et
trébuchantes et le la déclaration
irresponsable que on va faire adhérer la
turquie à l'union européenne pour moi ce
n'est pas responsable et ce n'est pas
avoir une juste idée de ce que l'avenir
européen doit être l'europe ça doit être
l'union de pays et de société qui
partage le même
au fond le même espace géographique
géopolitiques et les mêmes valeurs de
société les mêmes visions de la société
et franchement vous voyez bien qu'en
turquie aujourd'hui c'est pas cette
orientation qui a été prise alors par
rapport aux visions deux sociétés ont
valeur
à l'actualité est aussi la coop 21 cet
événement de portée internationale ces
retours de la conférence sur le climat
est ce que c'est bien parti est-ce que
c'est mieux partis que là que la lutte
contre le terrorisme par exemple bon
c'est un c'est un grand machin c'est une
grand messe quand on dit machin c'est
connoté
ouais vous n'y croyez pas eloi cij
j'espère que ça va déboucher sur un
accord ambitieux et contraignant et sur
les deux quads voilà tout le monde le
dit venez donc enfin j'espère que ça va
se faire
et g oui en effet quelques inquiétudes
sur l'issue
alors avant l'issue en réalité je au
fond de moi même je crois pas beaucoup
aux grands messes c'est à dire ou penser
qu'il va y avoir des engagements et qui
seront pas tenues c'est ça ah je pense
que ça ressemblera peut-être hélas à ce
qui s'était pas ce qui s'est passé pour
les autres coop alors à copenhague
c'était carrément en échec l'a fait bon
voilà j'espère que ce sera moins un
échec à copenhague
est-ce que vous voit pas beaucoup je ne
peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir un certain
scepticisme vis-à-vis de deux de ses
rencontres nombre de ces grands macha de
ces grandes mises en scène de ses grands
de photos il ya 150 chefs d'état -
heures
- - poutine moi non mais il était là
mais pas sur la photo non mais il est
venu il s'est arrangé pour être en
retard et on peut comprendre aussi
voilà vous voyez bien la gravité de
l'incident qui la séparait de la turquie
et le fait qu'ils veuillent manifester
tout ça tout ça n'est pas n'est pas
étonnant je crois pas beaucoup aux
photos avec 150 chefs des mois je crois
pas qu'on ait des discussions sérieuses
ou qui débouche uniquement sous cette
forme
je salue les intentions je pense
qu'elles sont pour la plupart des
intervenants sincère mais je suis un peu
sceptique sur les la réalité des
résultats vers la fin de la coop 21
c'est le 13 décembre sept jours du
second tour alors on va parler second
tour des régionales on va pas justement
des régionales les algues aux oui si
françois hollande connaît une embellie
dans les sondages ça ne semble pas
devoir se traduire dans les intentions
de vote dimanche premier tour et
dimanche 2e tour on voit que c'est le fn
qui a une dynamique actuellement avec
même entre deux et six régions sont les
estimations qui pourrait être à la
portée du front national nicolas sarkozy
martèle son message lui ni fusion ni
retrait ni désistement ni front
républicain
est ce que c'est votre position à vous
est ce que au soir du premier tour la
question pourrait se poser pour vos
listes puisque vous êtes associé à vous
engager vous avez dit deux choses la
première c'est qu'il y avait pas de
report de l'embellie de françois
hollande sur les listes du ps sur la
gauche un rien n'est plus normal ce qui
est salué par les français dans les
sondages et on sait que les sondages cet
épisode i kass ça monte puis après ça
descend chacun d'entre nous le sait ce
qui est salué c'est la posture de chef
de l'état c'est pas le ps
et même si on voulait regarder la
plupart des mesures qui ont été
annoncées par françois hollande et qui
font son regain de popularité ce sont
des mesures que le ps rejeter n'hésitez
pas qu'ils sont à dissocier attendez
laissez
moi laissez moi aller au bout je vais je
vais répondre donc de ce point de vue là
c'est normal et les français sont
toujours dans l'esprit de jugé avec
sévérité la politique qui a été menée
depuis des années par le parti
socialiste au pouvoir et les chiffres de
l'emploi en octobre que plus 42 mille
chômeurs vont tout à fait dans ce sens
donc il y a une volonté je crois des
français de sanctionner saprophytes ça
c'est une première chose
deuxièmement il ya en effet selon les
sondages une montée du front national
et c'est normal aussi devient vos cernes
atlantis est monté oui peut-être dans
les pyrénées atlantiques un peu moins
que partout ailleurs mais c'est normal
étant donné qu'il pourrait y avoir une
alternative qui s'appelle les
républicains et le centre est
ce nom c'est normal parce que le front
national s'est instituée en opposant
universel troisième force et on l'a
laissé s'instituer en opposant universel
mais attendez on a fait ce qu'il fallait
et donc alors et donc je viens je viens
à la question il ya eu des propos en
effet de nicolas sarkozy qui dit aucun
retrait de nulle part pour personne est
ce que ça vous engage ce sont des propos
de premier tour c'est à dire cela vous
enverra dire que avant le premier tour
ce je comprends très bien il est normal
que les responsables politiques
mobilisent leurs électeurs parce que si
vous disiez le contraire les électeurs
évidemment son n'irai donc il ya une
volonté de mobiliser les électeurs
au soir du premier tour on verra la
situation électorale et chacun devra
juger donc de sa responsabilité veut
dire quoi précisément c'est quoi chacun
et nous les choses bages je dis les
choses simplement
chacun devra juger de sa responsabilité
chacun devra regarder la gravité du
risque électoral qui se présentera et
chacun devra s'exprimer ça veut dire que
je ne manquerai pas à cette obligation
nicolas sarkozy également il ne pourra
pas selon vous il ne pourra plus tenir
les mêmes propos dimanche soir que
mercredi matin chez dit exactement ce
que je voulais nommé 6 1
engagé par les propos de nicolas sa veux
dire clairement que je fais la
différence entre le premier tour et le
deuxième est entre la gauche entre la
gauche et le front national
et je fais la différence entre les les
hiérarchies de risque nous parlerons de
tout ça c'est légitime que chacun
mobilise son électorat c'est légitime
que que les français est un choix assez
sale premier tour qu'ils puissent
exprimer ce choix et nouvelle mouture
ficelles qui l'enfer pourront faire
barrage au front national
vous savez quelle est ma philosophie
exactement et entraîneur je ne j'ai
parlé de hiérarchie du risque
un chacun devra juger quelle est la
hiérarchie je vais à traduire
je vais la traduire en faisant de périph
parce que je ne veux pas ouvrir une
polémique dans une ambiance électorale
nicolas sarkozy s'exprime je m'exprime
et puis chacun gérait 1 après jésus
présent sur 12 des 13 10 en fait je vais
traduire ce que vous dites vous dites au
soir du premier tour les listes et l'air
et modem
elle devrait être présente partout si ça
vous avez vous dire non ou j'ai mal
compris monsieur ce que j'aime bien
monsieur aziz
c'est votre sens de l'humour c'est à
dire le le le goût que vous avez des
formule provocatrice
il se trouve que deux la gg dit
exactement ce que je voulais il est
temps contre il ya deux actes
le premier tour en état au premier tour
chacun donc essaie de mobiliser son
électorat et c'est légitime et normal et
le reste du premier après le résultat du
premier plus raide pour chacun d'eux
rédigeant ses responsabilités il
totalisera pleinement exactement donc
plutôt perdre une élection que son âme
jeu de formule là une formule que michel
noir est utilisé il ya de très longues
années en 1988 si j'ai faim si j'ai une
bonne mémoire des dates ou
ou tout début de 1989 et ça fait quand
même 26 mai alors c'est peu dire des
formules qui sont toujours valables
alors il ya aussi quelque chose qui
frappe en cette semaine on a vu pierre
gattaz monté au créneau contre le fn
dans le parisien hier la voix du nord
sangay s'est engagé dans deux une lundi
et mardi à démasquer
selon sa formule le front national ils
ne sont pas ce qu'ils disent être de la
une
la voix du nord c'est la société civile
aujourd'hui qui mène le combat contre le
fn c'est les politiques n'y arrive plus
ils sont plus audibles alors un tout le
monde a le droit de s'exprimer dans une
circonstance politiques notamment
circonstances politiques jugé grave
j'ai lu ici ou là que la voix du nord
n'aurait pas dû prendre position que
monsieur gattaz aurait pas dû prendre
position la responsabilité du citoyen
c'est de juger quand on doit s'expliquer
vous approuvez saisine s'était donc non
je dis que chacun a la légitimité de
s'exprimer et je ne mets pas en cause
cette légitimité là j'ai vu des
déclarations qui disait gattaz en fait
ils aident le français jean-luc
mélenchon jean louis j'ai dit il ya nice
était même pas ça lydiate d'idiot utile
de front national très bon et donc je ne
je ne prends pas ce genre de position là
est ce que le est-ce que c'est efficace
est ce que le refus ou est-ce que le
combat contre les thèses extrémistes
doit être le seul fait des partis
politiques je ne le crois pas je pense
même que les partis politiques ne sont
que l'expression de la société et vous
voyez bien à la société aujourd'hui elle
cherche une autre voie que celle qui ont
été suivis depuis des années alors vous
allez retrouver là quelque chose qui
pour moi comme une obsession depuis des
temps et des temps jeu je ne crois pas
que nous ayons la vie politique que la
france mérite
je ne crois pas que nous ayons la vie
politique que la société française
attend je pense qu'il va y avoir qu il
doit y avoir de grands changements
c'est pourquoi je suis un peu distingué
ou assez fortement distingué des forces
politiques traditionnelles qui veulent
eux que ou qui croient pouvoir défendre
l'idée que ça dure comme ça je ne crois
pas mais avant je pense que ça ne va pas
et donc mais ça ne va pas et la pression
doit venir aussi de la société civile
comme on dit est ce que venir des
citoyens des pères de famille des
salariés
quand vous dites ça ne va pas un est ce
que vous faites une comparaison avec les
années 30
et est ce que pour vous la force du
front national dans les sondages est une
vraie alerte ou est-ce que c'est comme
vous dites l'opposant universelle qui
traduit un malaise mais comme comment
vous analyser la situation
bon c'est une question extrêmement
difficile et s koné comme dans les
années 30
heureusement pas tout à fait lorsque les
thèmes des années 30
c'était des thèmes qui étaient
extraordinairement influencé par comment
dirais-je une très grande violence y
avait des ligues
il y avait des émeutes il y avait des
organisations paramilitaires
c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
heureusement il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
croître tant d une question justement
justement attendez une seconde non mais
vous avez parlé de l'est sont finir les
phrases parce que ce sont des sujets
graves à jeu je suis ravi que vous mmes
interrompre y est quand ce sont des
sujets qui se prête au ping pong
ça c'est pas trop le sujet il n'y a pas
de croix de feu aujourd'hui par unis si
pâle qui se met en place
robert ménard vous avez vu oui bon pas
trop une garde biterroise ils appellent
ça des anciens militaires des anciens
policiers à la retraite qu'ils
pourraient être armés et patrouiller
dans la ville
nous pourrions citoyens vous voyez que
vous voyez que on peut pas finir mais
non mais
c'est très non je dis que les années 30
c'est notamment marquée par les anciens
combattants de la guerre de 14 il faut
avoir en tête que 34 c'est seulement 18
ans après la fin de la guerre de 14
qu'il y a des millions d'anciens
combattants dans la société française
des millions d'anciens combattants
blessés dans leur chair dans leur idée
sentiment qu'on les reconnaît pas que la
politique traditionnelle a repris sa
place et que le qui avaient donné leur
leur chair et leur vie pour 1 million
400 mille d'entre eux pour la patrie
n'était pas reconnue c'est une présence
qui est tout à fait obsédante et avec
une grande donc de grandes organisations
avec des millions de membres donc on en
est à l'arrêt donc je ne je ne je ne
crois pas que ce soit la même chose il
ya une chose qui me frappe c'est le
climat de décomposition ou en tout cas
c'est le climat de des connexions de
rupture entre la vie politique et
l'expression des citoyens
alors justement ça c'est un signe
extraordinairement inquiétant raison ce
problème ni appel à de grands
changements que qui à mon sens devront
venir nécessairement est nécessaire
maintenant si vous voulez parler deux de
ses gardes dans le gard paloise
je vais pas parler de béziers non je
veux dire simplement que je me suis
exprimé pour qu'il y ait une garde
nationale en france
amusé par ce que parce que vous voyez
bien que les policiers ont besoin dead
ont besoin d'eux
quand on pense au temps perdu avec les
tâches administratives des policiers et
des gendarmes
oui il ya besoin d' aide pour garder des
lieux publics pour faire attention
est-ce que ça doit être municipal
évidemment non vous n'allez pas avoir
36000 communes qui vont se mettre à
bâtir leur propre système de sécurité
tout ça n'a évidemment eu un sens est
d'ailleurs fondé sur un seul objectif
qui est la communication il reste six
minutes beaucoup de questions on
poursuit sur le disais il faut il faut
qu'ils ont grand changement ce thème du
changement et donc on va parler de
l'après élections régionales et on va se
passer sur ce que claude bartolone
disait ici la semaine dernière après les
élections il faut un élargissement du
gouvernement
un élargissement de la majorité quand on
a cité votre nom il a dit pourquoi pas
bayrou au gouvernement qu'auriez vous
dit chiche ou pas écouter vous savez
pourquoi les changements politiques que
j'appelle de mes voeux depuis longtemps
ils ne peuvent pas se produire dans le
sauve qui peut ils ne peuvent pas se
produire dans le une espèce de sentiment
d'affolement généralisée comme celui qui
suivrait comme celui qui suivraient
une défaite électorale rude c'est
impossible
et si sujet beaucoup de conversations
avec françois hollande sur ce sujet
depuis quand depuis repris depuis 2012
lorsque nous avons parlé très souvent de
cette de cette idée je lui ai dit si
vous voulez faire ce qu'il faut faire en
france faut que vous ayez en tête une
chose
une maxime qui est que tard c'est trop
tard
il a vraiment raté roche oui je pense
oui
or vous voyez bien on fait pas d re
on ne remet à pas les cartes simplement
parce que la foudre tombe parce que à ce
moment là vous vous exposez dans
l'opinion
s'il y avait un projet de
reconfiguration de la vie politique
vraiment il aurait été efficaces s'ils
étaient intervenus tôt aujourd'hui vous
voyez bien très grand défi quand je
l'examinerai oui mais que voulez que je
participerai aux débats temps je suis
persuadé que nos institutions
enfin en tout cas que les règles que
nous nous sommes donnés empêchent le
pays de retz poudre de répondre alors
pas parmi les règles ya quoi y'a le
changement éventuellement de mode de
scrutin que vous réclamez depuis des
années du reporter oui depuis des années
des années des années la proportionnelle
s'il françois hollande à propose de la
mettre en place après les régionales
mais témoin une réflexion à ce propos on
est en train de dire front national
combien de régions
c'est ça que vous dites tous ceux qui
croyaient naval avait déjà qu'un système
les médias dits à cette place même qu'un
système majoritaire protéger contre les
extrêmes vous avez dit c'est une digue
qui peut sauter voilà vont s'apercevoir
que c'est précisément ce système
majoritaire là qui offrent sur un
plateau le pouvoir aux extrêmes dès
l'instant que la goutte d'eau fait
déborder le vase c'est à dire dès
l'instant que vous arriver premier quel
que soit votre score et bien vous
recevez le pouvoir en entier ce qui est
entre nous
une grande un plus proportionnelle
proportionnelle et dont les mon idée à
moi depuis touche cours qui est l'idée
je vais vous raconter une histoire en
trois phrases
j'étais très ami avec helmut kohl
j'étais très très jeune et il était déjà
mûr
avant même qu'il ne devienne chancelier
et je lui disais mais avec la naïveté de
mon jeune âge de mes 20 ans je lui
disais comment ça se fait que vous les
allemands vous changez jamais
d'institutions il m'a dit écoute moi
bien
lorsque enfin écoute moi bien nous les
allemands nous avons eu dix ans pour
penser à ce qui avait amené au pouvoir
de hitler et on était en train de mourir
comme patrie et comme nation et les plus
intelligentes d'entre nous on réfléchit
à un système et ce système nous a sauvés
de glace des vernets a répondu
précisément la question si françois
hollande ou est-ce que vous encourager
françois hollande à réformer le mode de
scrutin législatif après des régionales
c'est à dire à mettre en place la
proportionnelle pour 2017 son pensionnat
l'intégrale chaque fois que ce sujet
sera abordé je participerai au débat
mais je considère que dans l'urgence
c'est beaucoup plus difficile que si on
avait posé cette question centrale à
faire et le début la calle reina est
pour moi
je crains que les polémiques ne nuise à
un projet pourtant vital pour le pays
alors le projet c'est la présidentielle
vous êtes derrière alain juppé on croit
on croit pouvoir penser que vous estimez
que la jupe est un peu de chances de
passer
c'est ce qui s'écrit dans certains
journaux ces housses cultivant tellement
nicolas sarkozy ce que dit nicolas
sarkozy ça ça je suis assez prêt à vous
qu'on la résidence il reçu à ces prêts à
vous croire
si alain juppé choisi je l'aiderai non
mais si lepage mêmes allons plus loin je
l'aide devrait être choisi suivez pas
choisir c'est être je l'aiderai à dire
être choisie c'est à dire que beaucoup
de mes amis de mes proches ont
l'intention de s'engager pour que alain
juppé puisse remporter cette compétition
donc simplement ce que vous avez entendu
et que j'ai dit souvent
moi je ne me reconnais pas dans les
primaires parce que les primaires c'est
une espèce de 2,2 prime à la surenchère
c'est comme ça que ça marche il suffit
que vous regardiez les primaires
américaines
avec donald trump et dogan qui n'a pas
gagné
contesté dans les primaires américaines
non pas par un candidat plus central
n'est pas un candidat plus à droite
donc c'est comme ça c'est l'excitation
ne restait la ville madjer et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je doute du
mécanisme des primaires dans lesquels
dans lequel je ne reconnais pas la
cinquième récit
si alain juppé échoue vous serez
candidat écoutez si alain juppé échoué
je serai libre et vous serez essais et
ces trois mots sont suffisamment
explicites est votre modèle c'est plutôt
giscard avec ses 2 français sur 3 78
françois mitterrand avec la france une
itt 88 je ne sais pas du tout j'ai bien
connu là et l'autre et je pense que
l'histoire ne repasse jamais les plats
on ne il faut toujours inventer des
modèles nouveaux et pas se fier à des
modèles qui est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
diriez que marine le pen peut remporter
la présidentielle de 2017 compte tenu du
climat
en tout cas je ferai tout pour empêcher
une telle hypothèse de se réaliser
et qu'est ce qui fait qu'on a envie de
présenter république depuis des années
des années qu'on a encore envie de
redevenir en 2017
cette responsabilité pour moi elle n'est
pas du domaine de l' envie de dans la
vocation politique il ya bien des choses
dont j'ai envie je n'ai jamais classé la
présidence de la république au nombre de
ces choses simplement
je sais que c'est la seule élection qui
peut permettre de changer les choses
c'est la seule élection qui peut
permettre de changer le centre de
gravité de la politique française et à
la fin est de faire naître une pratique
nouvelle pour que les français dans nom
soit plus à des votes qui sont autant
d'impasses et de manière si c'est la fin
de questions d'info
merci françois bayrou d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation merci à vous de nous
être fidèles et à la semaine prochaine
merci